foreign
is up in Temecula California Terry how
can we help
hey can you guys hear me okay loud and
clear
awesome pleasure speaking to you guys
today
um got a quick question regarding
um kind of a difficult work conversation
I'm going to have to have um I'm an
insurance agent I sell a Property and
Casualty so Auto home
umbrella that type stuff and I just
recently got my life insurance license
last week and so it's time for me to
talk to my boss about
um you know I I don't believe in whole
life or uh universal life
in line with what you guys
um you know kind of preach here and so
how should I have that conversation with
my boss and just kind of looking for
some ways in there yeah so before we
talk about how
what what's the point that you're going
to be making what's the very clear thing
you want your boss to hear don't worry
about how to word Smith it just tell me
Point Blank go
yeah I just want to make it clear that I
have no intention on on ever promoting
or selling Universal or whole life
insurance okay great and
are you required to offer or to sell it
in a and if you're talking to somebody
are you required is that something that
they're making sure you do or is it just
uh one product in a buffet if you will
yeah it's just one product in a buffet I
would say um so you're not required to
sell it the upper term insurance as well
I'm not required at all to sell it no
but I mean the expectation is there that
I'm asking about life insurance and and
pushing that which obviously I believe
in life insurance
um you know term insurance but yeah
um
yeah and I understand the expectation is
there and I'm leading to answering your
question directly but I'm trying to get
true context here
I understand the expectation is there
because it's one of the products on the
buffet if you will okay but are they
actively checking up on this and
monitoring this is this something that
you're going to have to confront sooner
or later
I I think I will have to confront it too
early all right so that's all I wanted
to know because I you know to the point
that it's not like an aggressive thing
that you have to do I wouldn't bring it
up right now but if you're going to have
to deal with it sooner or later then
that's fine
um but what do you think the reaction is
going to be
I'm honestly not sure
um I've got a really good relationship
with the agency owner and it's a fairly
small agency that I work at uh there's
four of us in the office and
um you know I am the top producer in the
office as far as selling auto and home
great and so I'm not I'm not worried
about like losing my job per se but
you know I just I just want to make sure
I'm going about the conversation no I
got an opinion I got an opinion but I
but but I want to know one other
question so are the other products so
everything but whole life are they as
profitable for the agency his whole life
or his whole life more profitable
whole life is certainly the most
profitable that's what I thought all
right so you're gonna have to make a
business case on this and and when you
go in and I think you got to go in not
with a uh posture of uh being indignant
uh but just go in and be humble and and
very clear Hey listen just want you to
know
um I don't believe in this product I'm
not knocking you or anybody but I just
want to be up and up because I'm a
number one producer right now and I just
want to be very clear
um because it's going to come up
eventually why I'm not selling this and
I'm going to make the company a bunch of
money I'm going to make a lot of people
very happy and taking care of them but I
can in good conscious conscience
um uh sell whole life and now what you
can't do is get sucked into a debate but
if you've got a couple of key reasons as
to why you'd lay that out very clearly
and then sit back and it's almost like
you're just gently pushing that you know
that plate across the table and go this
is how it's going to be if you feel like
you got to confront it now that's the
only way to do this and let's just you
know I think the fact that you're a
number one producer and the fact that
you've got clear convictions as to why
you won't sell it I think I think it's
uh that's all you can do I don't know
that there's any other way that you can
handle that
got it got it how does that sit with you
Terry I mean you said you this may go
very smoothly and he goes all right um
it's understood you're not going to sell
a whole life and if someone's adamant
about wanting it you might pass it off
to a different sales guy who goes oh my
gosh thank you so much this is great
thanks for the lead but I love that
you're sticking to your convictions and
your values and thank you for The
Insider tip now we can announce To
America that the reason they push whole
life is because it's way more profitable
than term life that's what I was right
Terry can you can you confirm that for
all of us listening
yes that is correct but Terry now that I
answered your question I'm now going to
challenge you you okay with that
sure
while we do not like whole life
insurance at Ramsey Solutions and we're
very very clear on our stance on that
the fact of the matter is you have
chosen to work for an agency that sells
that product and they're not going to
stop selling that product I doubt that
you're going to lay this out and he's
going to go Terry you're right as of
today we're getting rid of whole life as
a product and we're not going to sell it
anymore we're going to talk everybody
out of it like that's not gonna happen
right
right right so at some point you
probably need to be prepared to to go
out on your own or go with somebody else
who doesn't sell this product I'm just
telling you you I'm not knocking you I'm
just saying
this is a conflict here it's like
working in retail and they push the
store credit card and that's part of
your job is you got to do it and you
have to say listen I'm not going to push
the sore credit card yeah it's like hey
I'm working for you but I don't want to
sell your number one product
see you're laughing
because part of me would go well then go
work somewhere else this is our number
one problem right so I don't know how
it's going to go hope it goes well but
at some point you probably need to go
somewhere else is what I'm getting at
that's that's what I think right exactly
and and that is something that I have
you know thought about
um you know eventually like you said
either striking out on my own or going
to you know a uh you know an agency or
somewhere else that that doesn't promote
it or with people who are more in line
with with my values
um but uh you know I mean I've only been
insurance for been in insurance for
about a year now and this is I mean this
is the first agency I've worked at and
so now that I have my life licensed the
expectation is that I'm going to be
selling life insurance and so I just
wanted to have that conversation on the
front end and get ahead of it yeah again
I love your integrity
but the the what you laughed at is the
point that you're going to have to deal
with which is it's like going to work
for an automotive dealer is they sell
one thing and you go listen I I'm not
going to sell this one I'm only going to
sell the used cars of the other make be
like what the crap are you doing here so
I mean understand that that's what
you're going to be met with and as I
understand that as much as I disagree
with whole life I understand why they
would react that way there's other
insurance fish in the sea and our
friends at Xander insurance for example
don't sell whole life
and so there are companies out there who
aren't going to push these products so
there's other options for you if this
doesn't work out but I hope the
conversation goes great and you're there
for a long time and you're very happy
yeah there you go that's simple but hey
be prepared
to move on great reminder that whole
life is a rip-off from the inside you
heard it here first George you're so
spicy thank you wow